COMMITTEE THE PUBLIC WELCOME THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
EMPLOYEE IN RETIREMENT FOR YOU
AGAIN. WE'LL TAKE A FEW MINUTES
TO GO THROUGH A FEW OPTIONS AND
PROTOCOLS FOR THIS HEARING TODAY
. WELL STATE CAPITALS OPEN THE
PUBLIC AND WEARING A MASK IS NO
LONGER REQUIRED. WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THAT MASK BE WARNED
ALL. IN ALL COMMON AREAS AND
SHARED SPACES IN THE CAPITAL
INCLUDING THIS HEARING ROOM. WE
ALSO ENCOURAGE INDIVIDUALS TO
CONTINUE PRACTICING SOCIAL
DISTANCING. THE PUBLIC CAN
PARTICIPATE. IN PERSON OR ON THE
PHONE DURING THIS HEARING FOR
THE PUBLIC TO THE ROOM AND ROOM
FOR THE STATE CAPITOL WE'RE
MEETING. IF ANYONE THIS ROOM WAS
A TEST FOR THE BILL UNLESS YOU
COME FORWARD IF YOU APPROPRIATE
TIME TO PROVIDE YOUR TESTIMONY
BUT PLEASE DO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. AFTER DONE SPEAKING
YOU CONNECTS THE RURAL OR RETURN
TO YOUR SEAT IF YOU LEAVE THE
ROOM PLEASE LIMIT ELEVATOR USED
TO WHAT IS DESCRIBED ON SCIENCE
NEAR THE ELEVATORS. FURNACES
CALLING ON THE PHONE WILL ALSO
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE AT ONCE IS CAN USED TO
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALLING
NUMBER FOR THE HEARING IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
FOUR FOUR. THE FINEST PHONE
NUMBER ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AND ON YOUR TV COMPUTER
SCREEN. ONCE AGAIN THE NUMBER
EIGHT SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR. FOR CALLING IN PLEASE DO
SO AS YOU OFFER THE BILL BEGINS
PRESENTING THE BILL. THE
OPERATOR LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACED
IN THE QUEUE. DEPENDING ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. FOR CALLING IN PLEASE
LIMIT ALL BACKGROUND NOISE SUCH
AS MUTING YOUR TV. LIVESTREAM
BROADCASTS AND OTHER SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE INTERRUPTION.
AND SELF DISTORTION. PLEASE
REMAIN WITH US PROVIDING
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL YOUR MAN
I LIVE LINE IT WILL NEED TO MEET
YOURSELF. INTO YOUR CALLED ON TO
SPEAK. TO EVERYONE IS ALSO WHERE
WAS COMMITTEE ACCEPTS WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION.
LETTER PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AND ENCOURAGES THOSE WHO
HAVE ANY TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES
TO USE THIS OPTION. WE'RE
LIMITING TESTIMONY FOR PARTNER
WITNESSES FOR EACH BILL THE TWO
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT. AND TWO
PEOPLE IN OPPOSITION. EACH OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS WILL HAVE
THREE MINUTES MAXIMUM TO SPEAK.
IF THEY'RE LESS THAN TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES REGARDING ITS OF THIS
POSITION. THE MAXIMUM TWO
MINUTES STILL APPLIES. AFTER THE
PARTY WOULD ARE DONE. EVERYONE
ELSE TO BE FROM THE TO SAY
THERE. ORGANIZATION IF ANY
POSITION ON THE BILL. I'LL BE
OFF THE PHONE OPERATOR MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT SPEAKER WHEN YOUR
TIME IS UP. THE SAME IS
EXPERIENCING NUMBER OF
DISRUPTIONS TO THE COMMITTEE OF
FOR PROCEEDINGS THE LAST FEW
YEARS. SO EVERYONE IS CLEAR.
PANDAVAS DISRUPTS DISTURBS
PREMPEH THE ORDERLY CONDUCT THE
HEARING IS PROHIBITED. TO
ADDRESS ANY DESTRUCTIVE CONDUCT.
L. DIRECTING THE STOP AND ONE
INDIVIDUAL THE CONTINUE. DEBATE
THEY MAY BE REMOVED FROM
PARTICIPATING IN THIS HEARING.
THIS APPLIES TO IN PERSON AND
FULL PARTICIPATION IF NECESSARY
WHICH EMPLOYEE RECESSES HEARING.
THANK YOU VENTURE COOPERATION.
FOR THIS HEARING SOMEONE SAY OUR
TOOLS ABSENT SIMILAC YOU'LL BE
SUBSTITUTING. AND MISTER LUCKY
SHOULD BE HERE SHORTLY THAT WILL
SEVEN ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
INCLUDE TO ALL CONSENT THE TWO
BILLS ARE CONSENT OR FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB EIGHTEEN TWENTY
FOUR BY THIS COMMITTEE. FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO- STR FIVE BUT
CENTER WILL FINALLY FOR FOLLOW
NUMBER FOUR AB SIXTEEN NINETY
ONE SIMOUN MEMBER CALDERON WE'RE
PRESENTING FOR THE AUTHOR.
BEFORE WE BEGIN IT IS ESTABLISH
A QUORUM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
UBER PRESENT COOPER PRESENT
VOEPEL YOU'RE- A PRESENT
CALDERON. CALDERON COOLEY COOLEY
PRESENT LACKEY O'DONNELL. THANK
YOU TO HAVE A WE GOT A QUORUM
GREAT OKAY LET'S CONSENT CAL IS
A MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE IT ITEM
FROM THE CAN CALENDAR. SEEING
NONE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
POTION MISTER COOLEY SECOND
THING GET THE MOST SECOND. I
DON'T NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY FOR
THE MOTION IS TO PAY AND BE RE
REFER TO THE CAN ON
APPROPRIATION WITH
RECOMMENDATION TO CONCEPTO
THEIR- ITEM NUMBER TWO. SJR FIVE
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED TO
CONSENT CALENDAR. COOPER HI
COOPER I WILL TELL BY VOEPEL I
CALDERON BUT I DON'T I COOLEY HI
COOLEY AYE O'DONNELL LACKEY.
MAKING WE HAVE FOR BOTH PLACE A
LONG CALL WE'RE NOW WE'RE GOING
TO THE NEXT I ON THE J. STARTING
FILE I NUMBER THREE. AB SIXTEEN
OH FOUR SOME HOLDEN MEMBERS YOUR
BILL. ANYWAY THIS IS SUPPORT
THIS BILL. YES PLEASE COME
FORWARD. WE GOT MORE PERSON ONE
THE FOREIGN TOLD OKAY THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SAID TODAY I'M
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN
OH FOR A BILL THAT IDENTIFIES
REFORMS- REFORM PROCESSES THAT
HINDER UPWARD OBILITY FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN THE CIVIL
SERVICE SYSTEM. THIS BILL IS
IDENTICAL TO AB ONE OH FIVE FROM
LAST YEAR WHICH THIS COMMITTEE
SUPPORTED. MEMBERS AS YOU MAY
RECALL THE GENESIS OF THIS BILL
IS A CONSEQUENCE OF A SERIES OF
LETTERS WRITTEN AND PUBLISHED IN
THE SACRAMENTO BEE LAST YEAR ON
BEHALF OF AFRICAN AMERICAN.
EMPLOYEES WORKING AT
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
AND OUR CRAWL FOR YOUR PRISON
SYSTEM. AND THE OFFICE OF STATE
PUBLISHING. THE COMMON THEME OF
ALL OF THESE STORIES IS THAT
THERE'S A LACK OF UPWARD
MOBILITY INCLUSION IN OUR CIVIL
SERVICE SYSTEM. AND TWENTY
TWENTY THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY
SUPPORTED AND GOVERNOR NEWSOM
SIGNED MY BILL AB NINE SEVENTY
NINE WHICH REQUIRES EACH
PUBLICLY HELD CORPORATION WHOSE
PRINCIPAL EXECUTIVE OFFICERS.
OFFICES ARE LOCATED IN
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE MINIMUM
NUMBER OF DIRECTORS FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES ON
ITS BOARD OF DIRECTORS. THIS IS
A PRAISE WORTHY STEP FOR
EMPLOYEES IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
HOWEVER THERE ARE PERPETUAL
BARRIERS TO UPWARD MOBILITY THAT
EXISTS IN OUR PUBLIC SECTOR
CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM. IT IS IN
THIS SPIRIT THAT I PUT FORWARD A
NUMBER OF CIVIL SERVICE REFORMS
THAT ARE REFLECTED IN AB SIXTEEN
OH FOUR. FOR STARTERS AB SIXTEEN
OH FOUR CALLS FOR DIVERSITY ON
ALL STATE BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
THAT HAVE VOLUNTEERS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL REQUIRES
THAT THE STATE PERSONNEL BOARD
ESTABLISH A PROCESS THAT
INCLUDES DIVERSITY AND BEST
PRACTICES IN EACH ASPECT OF
DESIGN. THAT ANNOUNCEMENTS AND
ADMINISTRATION OF EXAMINATIONS
FOR THIS TABLETS MEANT OF
EMPLOYMENT LISTS. AB SIXTEEN OH
FOUR PROVIDES THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES
MAY UNDERSCORE MAY DEVELOP MODEL
UPWARD MOBILITY GOALS TO INCLUDE
RACE GENDER AND LBGT Q. AS
FACTORS TO EXTENT PERMISSIBLE.
UNDER STATE AND FEDERAL EQUAL
PROTECTION LAWS THIS BILL
REQUIRES THAT CAL HR SUBMIT
WITHIN ITS ANNUAL WORKFORCE
ANALYSIS AND CENSUS REPORTS ALL
OF THE ADVERSE ACTIONS TAKEN BY
DEPARTMENTS AGAINST EMPLOYEES.
IT CALLS FOR THE REPORT TO
INCLUDE THE TYPE OF ADVERSE
ACTION ETHNICITY GENDER AND
SEXUAL ORIENTATION IF AVAILABLE.
THE GOAL IS TO SEE IF THERE ARE
PATTERNS OF DISCRIMINATION IN
THE DEPARTMENTS. AB SIXTEEN OH
FOUR CALLS FOR STATE AGENCIES TO
COLLECT AND REPORT DEMOGRAPHIC
DATA USING MORE NUANCE
CATEGORIES OF CALIFORNIANS OF
AFRICAN DESCENT. SIMILAR TO THE
DATA COLLECTED FOR CALIFORNIANS
OF ASIAN DESCENT THIS DATA IS
CRITICAL TO ACCURATELY REPORTING
WHO AMONG CALIFORNIA'S AFRICAN%
AMERICAN DESCENT. ARE AFRICAN
DESCENT IS EXPERIENCING BARRIERS
TO UPWARD MOBILITY. THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY SUPPORTED IN
GOVERNANCE AND SIGNED A B.
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE AUTHORED
BY FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER DR
SHIRLEY WEBER ESTABLISHING THE
TASK FORCE TO STUDY AND DEVELOP
pREPARATION PROPOSALS FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS. AB SIXTEEN OH FOUR
GIVES THE TASK FORCE MORE
ACCURATE DATA TO UTILIZE IN ITS
DELIBERATIONS. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN
OH FOUR MNU AM FOR CO FOUNDER
DIRECTOR ABOUT REACH CAL
COALITION OF BLACK EMPLOYEES.
AND CHRIS LOXTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR JUST
AND EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA. AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. WELCOME HOLDEN
APARTMENT THIS IS A- GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE CHANCE TO SPEAK AND-
IS YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI SIXTEEN
OH FOUR THE UPWARD MOBILITY ACT
OR YOU ARE MAY TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. MY NAME IS CHRIS LARSEN AS
MENTIONED WITH THE COALITION FOR
JUST AND EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN WHO DESCENDS
FROM PERSONS INFLATE IN THESE
UNITED STATES AS SUCH I LIVE
WITH THE CURRENT IMPACTS OF THAT
HISTORY WHICH INCLUDE BOTH
DISCRIMINATION IN HIRING ON
STATE BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS. AS
WELL AS THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF
DISCRIMINATORY POLICY CREATED BY
THOSE SAME STATE ENTITIES BY
SUPPORTING THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
YOU IN MAY TWO DAY WHICH AMONG
OTHER THINGS REQUIRE STATE
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS WITH
VOLUNTEER MEMBERS TO BE MORE
INCLUSIVE OF PEOPLE LIKE ME. YOU
HELP INCENTIVIZE ENSURE AND
ENFORCE UPWARD MOBILITY AND
THEREBY DIRECTLY CONFRONT
LINGERING RACIAL INEQUITY. IN
STATE EMPLOYMENT AND POLICY.
IMPORTANTLY BUYS. THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO YOU IN MAY TWO DAY.
YOU HAVE A CHANCE TO DO
SOMETHING PARTICULARLY SPECIAL
AND NECESSARY INDEED HISTORIC
AND LONG OVERDUE. YOU HAVE A
CHANCE TO MOVE CALIFORNIA TOWARD
BEING THE FIRST DAY IN THE
NATION TO ACQUIRE DATA COLLECTED
AND USED BY STATE AGENCIES TO BE
DISAGGREGATED BY LIMITS. FOR
DIFFERENT BLACK OR AFRICAN
AMERICAN SUBGROUPS. SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE DO NOW FOR OUR API
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. AFRICAN
AMERICANS LIKE ME THOSE OF US
WHOSE ANCESTORS BUILT THIS
COUNTRY. WHO CAME HERE NOT BY
CHOICE BUT IN CHAINS WERE FORCED
TO WORK NEVER PAID AND TURNED
LOOSE WITH NOTHING. WE ARE A
UNIQUE GROUP OF AMERICANS. AND
BETTER MORE CLEAR DATA ON THE
DIFFERENT NEEDS OF THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN U. S. SLAVERY DESCEND
THE COMMUNITY. MEANS BETTER
POLICY. NOT ONLY WILL THIS BE AN
IMPORTANT AND HISTORIC
IMPROVEMENT IN THE WAY WE
COLLECT DATA ON AND FOR
CALIFORNIA'S BLACK COMMUNITIES.
NOT ONLY WILL IT PROVIDE CLARITY
AND DIRECTION TO STATE EFFORTS
TOWARD INCLUSIVE STATE BOARDS
AND COMMISSIONS. NOT ONLY WILL
PROVIDE CRITICAL INFORMATION TO
THE CALIFORNIA REPARATIONS TASK
FORCE WHICH IS RIGHT NOW POISED
TO DECIDE THE QUESTION OF
ELIGIBILITY FOR REPARATIONS. THE
CALIFORNIA OPERATIONS TASK FORCE
NEEDS THIS INFORMATION IN ORDER
TO MAKE REPARATIONS A REALITY
FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO DESCEND
FROM PERSONS INSULATE IN THESE
UNITED STATES LIKE MYSELF. TODAY
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO YOU MAY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
THAT'S WILL DEPRIVE ME WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
OPERATOR. THANK YOU POLICE ARMY
IF YOU HAVE SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WHAT
A LINE UP TWENTY. SECOND HERE
BOTTOM LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS JOHN
DIDN'T GO WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN OH
FOUR THANK YOU. OCTOBER LINE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS NICK WORLD
NOT WITH THE COALITION FOR
JACKSON ECKEL CALIFORNIA AND I
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE VOTE YES ON
AB SIXTEEN OH FOUR THANK YOU.
NEXT IN LINE. SEVENTEEN GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS CHAD BROWN
I'M WITH THE COALITION FOR JUST
AND EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA AND I'M
URGING YOU TO VOTE YES ON A. B.
SIXTEEN OH FOR TODAY THANK YOU.
NEXT LINE. FIFTEEN HI GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
KHAN SAID JOHN MUHAMMAD I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSEMBLY OF AMERICAN
SLAVERY DESCENDANTS OF LOS
ANGELES AND THE COALITION FOR
JUST AND EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE DISAGGREGATION
LANGUAGE M. A. B. ONE SIX FOUR
FOUR THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY FIVE REMAINS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS CAMILLE MOORE I'M
CALLING ON THE INDIVIDUAL ALSO
THE CHAIRPERSON OF THE
CALIFORNIA REPARATION PASSPORT
AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIXTEEN OH FOUR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT OVER THE LINE. TWENTY
SIX. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MARCUS CHAMPION WITH THE
COALITION FOR JACKSON HELLO
CALIFORNIA AND A NATIONAL
SINGING AMERICAN SLAVERY SINCE
LOS ANGELES AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN R. FOUR.
AND LAST ONE HERE IS LINE.
FOURTEEN GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
JOSIAH WILLIAMS FROM THE
AMERICAN REDRESS COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE COALITION FOR
JUST AND EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY NO
FOR PLEASE VOTE YES THANK YOU.
AND THEN FURTHER AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANOTHER
PRIMARY WITH US ON THE PHONE.
YES. PLEASE PROCEED ARE YOU ABLE
TO HEAR ME YES. OKAY YES GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS AMAN AMAN FOR
I AM THE DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE
AT LEAST FOR THE COALITION OF
BLACK EMPLOYEES- THE UPWARD
MOBILITY ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
TOO OFTEN ARE THEY BE MORE
SIXTEEN OKAY FOR. ITS
PROGRESSIVE STEP TO AFFECT
POLICY REFORMS BETTER
ACCOUNTABILITY TRAINING AND
TRANSPARENCY. WE THE CALL OF
BLACK AND ADVOCATE FOR RACIAL
EQUITY AND JUSTICE STATEWIDE.
WHERE MILLENNIALS GENERATION.
AND BABY BOOMERS WITH INDIVIDUAL
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE RANGING FROM
TWO TO THIRTY YEARS AFTER THE
SERVICE. CALIFORNIA DOESN'T
SUCCEED IN SPITE OF OUR
DIVERSITY. OUT STATE SIXTIES
BECAUSE OF IT I'M DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO BUILDING AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT REFLECTS
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE CITY AND AT
THAT GOAL I HOPE TO ADVANCE AT
EVERY LEVEL OF STATE GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS A QUOTE FROM GOVERNMENT
GAVIN NEWSOM. THIS IS THE TIME
TO ALIGN OUR WORDS AND TAKE HE
REQUIRED ACTIONS WE LIVE
DEMONSTRATE AN INTENTIONAL FOCUS
TO REDUCE DISPARITIES. IN
OPPORTUNITIES EXPERIENCES AND
OUTCOMES FOR ALL RESIDENTS BY
THE AND THE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. LEADERS SHOULD
EXPRESS THE COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESS HISTORICAL AND CURRENT
MANIFESTATION OF SOCIAL BIAS AND
EXCLUSION INCLUDING THE WAYS IN
WHICH SOCIAL ARRANGEMENTS
DISADVANTAGES SOME GROUPS
ILLEGITIMATE. THING THE JIMMY
OTHERS. CALIFORNIA ITS OWN TO BE
THE LEADER OF NATIONAL CHANGE BY
ESTABLISHING THE TASK FORCE TO
STUDY IN THE BALLPARK. PROPOSALS
PEOPLE BACK DESCENT AND A PUBLIC
HEALTH DOING PART DON'T ATTEND
THEM. CALIFORNIA'S MOST
CONSCIENTIOUS AND THE COUNTRY
WITH SO SUBJECT TO STAND. THE
CALL OF BLACK EMPLOYEES HAVE
SUPPORTED REPRESENTED SIXTEEN
OKAY. THE ENTIRE JOURNEY WHERE
MY- FATHERS SONS DAUGHTERS
BORDERS AND LEADERS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THE COALITION OF
BLACK EMPLOYEES THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
VOICES AND SUPPORTING OF SIGNING
AB. SIXTEEN OH FOUR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT MOVES THE OTHER
ONE IS IN THE ROOM PLEASE COME
FOR STATURE NAME ORGANISE IF ANY
IMPOSITION. CASING ON WITH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF PHONE.
WE HAVE ONE. JOHN LEVEL ON
BEHALF OF THREE PM CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION AND OF THE-
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
SUPERVISORS ORGANIZATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER LITTLE. ANY OTHER WITNESSES. YES GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS DARLENE
COMMITTEE AND I AM A MEMBER OF
THE COALITION FOR JESS AND
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA AND OUR
URGE YOU TODAY TO VOTE YES ON AB
SIXTEEN OH FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KIM
MA'AM TIME A COALITION FOR
JUSTIN EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA AND
AM IN THE MASS MEDIA AND I URGE
YOU TO VOTE YES. ON AB SIXTEEN
OH FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THIRD NO OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM WHEN WE WANT TO WIN THIS IS
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
PRIVATE WAIT PROMISES IN THE
ROOM TELEVISION TO THIS BILL. I
SEE NONE- PERMANENCE IS ON THE
PHONE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. OPERATOR KEEP AND IF SO
PLEASE PRESS ONE EIGHT ZERO
AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION. CURRENTLY NONE THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU MOVE ON TO
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THE ROOM. SEEING NONE ANOTHER
OPPOSITION IN THE IN THE- ON THE
PHONE SO WE'VE RECEIVED ALL
TESTIMONY WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. FROM THE MEMBERS AND
QUESTIONS. HER COMMENTS. I'M OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
SECOND WOMAN I SEE MISTER DONALD
HAS JOINED US QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR YES SIR I KNOW YOU MISS
THAT- RIGHT NOW SAYS FOR
VOLUNTEER COMMITTEES ONLY ZERO
DEDUCTIBLE TO. THAT'S ALL OF IT
THAT'S I CAN BE WITHOUT BUT WE
WE'VE GOTTEN A LEGAL OPINION
THAT SAYS THAT AS LONG AS IT'S
FROM LET'S COUNCIL. BUT IT'S
VOLUNTEERS AND NOT SALARIED OR
PAID EMPLOYEES THAT- IT DOES NOT
CROSS THE TO A NINE. FIVE ISSUE
AND BECOME AN ISSUE FOR THE
STATE SO VOLUNTEERS CANCER SO
WE'VE DONE IT FOR OUTSIDE
ORGANIZATIONS FOR BUSINESSES.
THIS IS APPLE BUT NOT TO STATE
EMPLOYEES ARE BOARDS. CORRECT
THIS IS THIS IS OUR ATTEMPT TO
ALSO DO THE SAME CORRECT RIGHT
NOW IT DOES APPLY TO THAT'S
CORRECT THE PRIVATE INDUSTRY
JUST NOT STATE GOVERNMENT YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT IRONIC. OKAY
THANK YOU ANOTHER QUESTION WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR. THE
FIRST AND SECOND- SING HEARING
ON. SIMILAR WITH THIS CLOSE.
PERSPECTIVE AS WE ARE ABLE.
THANK YOU. THE BILL THE MOVE BY
SUMMER COOLEY SAID BY BLUE THIS
THE ROLL- SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. I KNOW THREE A. B. C. OF
THE MOST IS TO PAY AND BE RE
REFER TO THE CAN ON A PER.
COOPER HI COOPER I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTE. CALDERON
CALDERON I FULLY ALL RIGHT
COOLEY O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I.
PLEASE THIS BILL WOULD BE PUT ON
FOR TWO ZERO. GOOGLE LOCAL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LET'S MOVE ITEM-
FONG NUMBER FOR A B. C. NINETY
MEDINA THE NEW PRESENTED BY
ASSEMBLY WOMAN CALDERON.
TWENTY SIX. I COULD MR CHAIRMAN
- TODAY PRESENTING S. BILL
NINETY ONE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEETING AB SIXTY NINETY
ONE WE MAKE THE SCHOOL EMPLOYEE
SUMMER ASSISTED PRO PROMOTE
WHILE ALSO INCREASING THE PRO
FOR TO ENSURE A DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR MATCH. A CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES ARE THE LOWEST PAID
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES MANY OF THEM
ARE WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
UNDER CURRENT LAW CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES WHO WORK AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE NOT ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE. IN THE SUMMER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THIS BILL
WOULD INCLUDE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES AND CREATE
PARITY BETWEEN ALL CLASSIFIED
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES IN THE
STATE. MAKING THE PROGRAM
PERMANENT WILL PROVIDE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES AND LITTLE
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES L. E.
AS- WITH INSURANCE AT THIS
PROGRAM WILL CONTINUE TO EXIST
AND MAKE CLEAR THAT IT IS NOT
JUST A SHORT TERM INVESTMENT.
THE AUTHOR WILL BE TAKING THE
MEASUREMENTS THAT CLARIFY
CERTAIN ELEMENTS AT THE BILL
HERE WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTEEN NINETY ONE. OUR
MERCEDES HER ALTHOUGH
INSTRUCTIONAL AIDE SPECIAL ED
CHAPTER PRESIDENT TO SIXTY FIVE.
AND REGIONAL ROUTE FORTY FOUR ON
THE PHONE AND PART WE'LL SPECIAL
ED ASSISTANT SEIU LOCAL NINETY
NINE ALSO ON THE PHONE. THANK
YOU SO WHAT TAKE PART IN THIS IS
A SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. PLEASE
COME FORWARD. WELL I DON'T SEE
ONE SAGA- PURPOSES SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE. OPERATOR PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME IN SUPPORT
OF HIS THIS IS PRIME EVAN THIS
IS A SUPPORT. AND WILL FIRST GO
TO LINE NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I IF YOUR PRIMARY WITNESS AND
TELL THEM THAT SO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I'M SORRY GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT MY NAME
IS MERCEDES GERALDO AND I'VE
BEEN WORKING AS THE THAT YOU
KNOW YUBA CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAS THAT INSTRUCTIONAL
ASSISTANT WITH SPECIAL EDUCATION
FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS. I MAKE
SURE THE STUDENTS I SUPPORT HAVE
ALL THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO
SUCCEED I AM A PROUD TO WORK AS
AN INSTRUCTIONAL AIDE BECAUSE I
KNOW I MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THE
LIVES OF STUDENTS AYE SIR. ALSO
CROWDS FIFTEEN MEMBER CHAPTER
PRESIDENT ORIGINAL RAP TO SAVE
REPRESENTS NEARLY TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES ACROSS THE
STATE. CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES ARE
THE BACKBONE OF OUR TO K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WE ENSURE SCHOOLS ARE CLEAN THE
CHILDREN ARE FAT AND GET TO
SCHOOL SAFELY WE DO THE WORK
MOST TAKE FOR GRANTED THE WORK
BUT NO ONE WANTS. HOWEVER MANY.
OF US STRUGGLE FINANCIALLY. LET
ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE AND I.
AIDE AFTER FIVE YEARS ONLY MAKE
ABOUT TWO TWO SOUTH DOLLARS A
YEAR. YOU KNOW ANYONE CONSERVE.
ON THAT. A TYPICAL SCHOOL YEAR
IS ABOUT TEN MONTHS AND MANY
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES ONLY WORKS
FOR TENANTS BASED. ON LIKE OTHER
WORKERS CLASSIFIED SCHOOL PLAYS
ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS DURING THE
SUMMER. COCKFIGHT MORE I'LL PUT
WHAT WELL I ON THURSDAY AND
CREDIT CARDS TO GET A THROUGH
THE SUMMER MY- BUDGET FAMILY
THEY- OFTEN DON'T HAPPEN TO A
LOT. AND TO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN LEGISLATOR CRAZY THE
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
SUMMER PROGRAM THIS PROGRAM
ALLOWS LOW WAGE CLASS SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES WHO WORK IN CASE FOR.
THIS A SMALL PORTION OF THEIR
PAGE EACH MONTH IN A TO RECEIVE
UP TO A TO ONE. FROM THE STATE
AND THE SUMMER. PROJECT IN THE
PER HAS ME DANTE. AND HAVE A
LITTLE EXTRA MONEY THIS ON
FAMILY BEFORE THE SCHOOL YEAR TO
GET. UNFORTUNATELY THE PROGRAM
IS NOT. YOUR IT APPLY TO.
EMPLOYEES WHO WORK FOR TO
COLLEGES. EIGHT SIXTEEN NINETY
WITH CARE THIRTY FOUR ALL OF OUR
CUSTOMER EMPLOYEE IN THE- I
WOULD CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH. AT THIS
POINT WILL. TO IN FUTURE YEARS.
AND MAKE CLEAR THAT IT NOT JUST
THIS PROGRAM. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR I. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. THIS REMOVAL ON OTHER
ONE IS IN SUPPORT THE ROOM. WHAT
WITH MORE ON THE PHONE THE PHONE
OKAY OUR NEXT PRIVATE PARTNER
WITH US IN THE FOR AND- OPERATOR. AND IF YOU DEL IN ITS PRIMARY
WITNESS YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND IF IT'S NOT OPENING YOUR
NEED YOUR LINE OPEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. HELLO MISTER LUCKY'S
JOINED US. OKAY REMOVE ON THE
OTHER WITNESSES SUPPORT THE ROOM. SEEING NONE MOVED OTHER WITH
US IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE.
PRESS ONE ZERO IT'S SO. AGAIN
IT'S ONE ZERO TO EXPRESS YOUR
SUPPORT. CURRENTLY. NINE
OKAY HAVING NONE. NO ONE THIS IS
ON THE PHONE OPERATOR. NO
WITNESS ON THE PHONE AT THIS
TIME OKAY NEXT MOVES THE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF THE
MEASURE. ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION OF THE ROOM.
SEEING NONE ALTHOUGH THIS IS AN
OPPOSITION OF THE PHONE OPERATOR. AND IF YOU ALLEN OF THE
PRIMARY WITNESS YOUR LINE IS
OPEN.
DEPENDING AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU NEXT MODEL UP OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF THE
ROOM. SINGLED OPPOSITIONS. WHEN
THIS IS OPPOSITIONAL PHONE.
OPERATOR PLEASE PRESS PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO TWO OPPOSED. HI.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PART WHILE
YOU'RE ON THE PHONE BUT THE-
WITH. SHOULD YEAH A PLEASE
PROCEED. AS PART WHILE. NO I
THINK THIS IS KIMBERLY
ROSENBERGER WITH AT THE ARE YOU
AND IF YOU'RE TECHNICAL HELP BUT
I'M TEXTING WITH PART ONE HOLE
IN THE THAT THEY CAN GET SO I AM
HI. I CAN'T THE LINE WITH SENATE
IT IS OPEN AT THIS TIME. IT IS
OPEN. YEAH PLEASE PROCEED. YOUR
LINES OPEN PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON I WAS BRING
BACK THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE. IS THERE A MOTION OR
SECOND. MOVED BY MISTER DONALD
SECOND MR COOLEY- THIS CALDERON-
THE CLOSING STATEMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FRIEND ABOUT.
OKAY METASPECTRUM CULTURAL
PLEASE. AB SIXTY NINETY ONE THE
DIP MOTION IS TO PASS AND BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HIGHER EDUCATION COOPER HI
COOPER AYE VOEPEL. VOEPEL NOT
VOTING. CALDERON I CALDERON I
COOLEY. COOLEY I. EAU DE I
LACKEY. LACKEY NOT VERY. THAT
MEASURES OUT ON AFFORD. ZERO
VOTE. OKAY THAT MAY OUT THERE
YOU. THIS THREE BILLS ARE
SOMEONE A- MOVE MISTER HOPE MY
ADVICE TO WILL TAKE OF.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. HERE FOR FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE. A. B.
SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN PLEASE BEGIN
. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES
ARE GENERALLY EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE
BEEN PROMOTED TO A SUPERVISORY
OR MANAGEMENT LEVEL IN MANY
INSTANCES MOST EMPLOYEE PROMOTES
THEY LOSE MANY PROTECTIONS THAT
ARE ENJOYED BY REPRESENTED
EMPLOYEES. WHAT IS PROTECTIONS
BINDING ARBITRATION AND EMPLOYEE
EMPLOYER GRIEVANCES WHEN BINDING
ARBITRATION IS USED IT PERMITS
DISPUTES TO BE SOLVED QUICKLY
AND A MUCH LOWER COST TO THE
EMPLOYEE AND EMPLOYER WHEN IS
NOT USE THOSE DISPUTES ARE TIME
CONSUMING COSTLY UNBALANCED AB
SEVENTY FOURTEEN WILL INCLUDE
BINDING ARBITRATION IN THE
EXCLUDED EMPLOYEE BILL OF
RIGHTS. THIS ALL. MULTILEVEL
GRIEVANCE PROCESS AND WILL
SURVIVE STUDENTS USED TO MAKE
FAIR AND EQUAL DECISIONS ON
EMPLOYEE GRIEVANCES. WITH ME
TODAY IS JOHN LEVEL REDUCING THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
SUPERVISORS ASSOCIATION- JOHN
LOCAL ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONS SUPERVISOR. SPONSORS
OF- OF- AB SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN-
THIS BILL WILL FIX A BROKEN
PROCESS RIGHT NOW WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT GRIEVANCES FROM EXCLUDED
EMPLOYEES ARE ALL DENIED WITH
MAYBE ONE OR TWO EXCEPTIONS BY
CAL CHAR WHY BECAUSE THEY CAN
IT'S TOTALLY ARBITRARY AND IT
LEAVES THE EMPLOYEE WITH THE
ONLY CHOICE OF JUST LETTING THE
GRIEVANCE GO DENIED. OR GOING TO
LITIGATION. NOW THE IRONY IS
THAT CALIPARI IT IS WRONG HEADED
RESULTS IN INCREASED COSTS COSTS
FIRST OF ALL LITIGATION IS
EXTRAORDINARILY EXPENSIVE FOR
BOTH THE EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION
AND FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SECONDLY JUDGMENTS IN LITIGATION
CAN BE VERY EXPENSIVE THERE'S A
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
JUDGMENT THAT WENT TO LITIGATION
THAT IF IT HAD GONE TO
ARBITRATION WOULD HAVE BEEN A
FRACTION OF THAT AND LITIGATION
JUDGMENTS HAVE PRECEDENTIAL
VALUE. SO A BAD JUDGMENT FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAN RESULT
IN A MOM ON MULTIPLICITY OF
JUDGMENTS ON THE OTHER HAND
ARBITRATION- DOES NOT HAVE
PRECEDENTIAL VALUE- SO THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS OF FOR THE-
OF FOR THE STATE THE OTHER
FEATURE OF THIS BILL. IS IT
PROVIDES THAT THE LOSING PARTY
IN AN ARBITRATION- SITUATION-
HAS TO PAY THE COSTS NOW WHAT
THAT MEANS IS THAT THE PARTIES
HAVE AN INCENTIVE THEM. TO TRY
AND NEGOTIATE A SETTLEMENT OF
THE GRIEVANCE I MEAN IF WE HAVE
A GRIEVANCE THAT GOES TO
ARBITRATION ON OUR SIDE WE
BETTER BE DARN SURE OF OUR-
EXPECTATION OF PREVAILING IN FOR
NOT THEN WE HAVE AN INCENTIVE TO
SIT DOWN WITH THE STATE AND TRY
AND RESOLVE THAT DISPUTE. THIS
IS VERY GOOD LABOR POLICY IT IS
VERY GOOD FISCAL POLICY-
UNHAPPILY- CAL HR HAS- HAD A
RIGID UNTHINKING OPPOSITION TO-
TO THIS BILL- AND THEY NEVER
COME TO THE LEGISLATURE TO DEFER
IN THEIR POSITION. THEY
BASICALLY HIDE IN THE BACK- AND
THEN WHEN THE BILL GOES TO THE
GOVERNOR THEY- WHISPER IN THE
GOVERNOR'S HERE WITH FACTUALLY
INACCURATE ASSERTIONS- AND- THEY
HAVE FOOLED TWO GOVERNORS WE'RE
GOING TO TRY AND- AND MOVE THIS
FORWARD SO THAT WE GET THE SAME
RESULT OF THIS TIME WE WANNA.
COMMANDMENTS TO COOPER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD IT IS
A GOOD SENSE AND GOOD LABOR
RELATIONS BILL AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE- TO SUPPORT THE BILL
AND SEND IT FORWARD. THANK YOU
OTHER OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE ROOM. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. VERY WELL THE TELESISTEMA
POSITION. WE DO HAVE ONE PARTY
ON THE PHONE OKAY VERY WELL. A
LINE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
PASSED AROUND WITH THEIR IN RENO
SO SEATS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANY OTHER IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. THREE ONE
ZERO IF SO. GIVE US JUST A
MOMENT HERE. THAT ONE AN
OPERATOR. CAN WE GO TO LINE
TWENTY NINE. BAKER WITH A
WITNESS SERVICES FOR THE
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS IN
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT SUPPORT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. VERY
WELL ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE.
KARNATAKA'S A WELL NOT HEARING
ANY MORE. OPPOSITION WITNESSES
IN THE ROOM. DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE. PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
OPPOSE. AGAIN IT'S. ONE ZERO.
CERTAINLY NOT AT THIS TIME. VERY
WELL LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ABOUT. THAT'S RIGHT. WE
HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES- I
CONSIDER ANY BETTERTHAN THIS TO
LOW LEVELS THAT IT- THIS COVERS-
MANAGEMENT SUPERVISORY BECAUSE
PRETTY MUCH. THE MAJORITY OF
YOUR LINE STAFF HAVE BINDING
ARBITRATION ALREADY IN CALAIS
CIARA AGREEMENT PERCENT- THEY
WILL NEVER COME FOR TO TALK
ABOUT THESE ISSUES AND REALLY
WORK IT OUT WITH YOU KNOW
LITIGATION IS MUCH MORE
EXPENSIVE FOR THE STATE MUCH
MORE EXPENSIVE FOR THE UNIONS SO
IT'S JUST. THERE'S REALLY NO
REASON OTHER JUST BEING
OBSTRUCTIONIST ON KELLY CHARGE
PART NOT JUST THIS BILL THE
OTHER BILLS AND OBSESS WITH
INTERPRETATIONS MUCH CHEAPER AND
IN THE DAY THE LOSER OF THE WITH
THE BILLS WRITTEN. HAS TO PAY
THE COURT COSTS SIDE I BELIEVE
THAT ISN'T INCENTIVIZE FOLKS TO
RESOLVE THINGS BUT THERE'S NO
REASON THESE FOLKS WHO WERE WHO
WE TRUST TO LEAD AND MANAGE IN
THE STATE. SHOULD HAVE THE SAME
PROTECTIONS THAT THEIR STAFF
GETS ITS BINDING ARBITRATION
THAT THAT'S VERY REASONABLE IT'S
CHEAP IT'S MUCH QUICKER THAN
GOING TO THE COURT SYSTEM SOME
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WE HAVE A MO WE HAVE A SECOND.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON AB SEVENTEEN FOURTEEN. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY COOPER HI COOPER AYE
VOEPEL AYE VOEPEL AYECALDERON.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T AYE COOLEY
AYE COOLEY AYE O'DONNELL WELL
DONE I THANK HE HI LACKEY I THAT
BILL IS OUT SIX TO ZERO. IN THE
BILL PASSES OUT APPROVED. THAT
BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY TWO MISTER
COOPER. THANK YOU MR CALL
FIREFIGHTERS AND OTHER PUBLIC
SAFETY EMPLOYEES FACE INHERENT
DANGERS IN THEIR JOBS THAT NON
SAFETY EMPLOYEES ARE NOT SUBJECT
TO. FIREFIGHTERS ARE FIVE MORE
TIMES LIKELY TO SUFFER RECLAIMED
INJURIES COMPARED TO NON SAFETY
EMPLOYEES R. P. THAT AGAIN FIVE
MORE TIMES CURRENT LAW PROTECTS
THE TEAM MEMBERS WHO GET INJURED
ON THE JOB BY NOT FORCING THEM
OUT OF THEIR USUAL DUTIES BEFORE
THEY MEET THEIR RETIREMENT AGE.
CURRENT LAW ALSO PROTECTS FIFTY
MEMBERS FINAL RETIREMENT
COMPENSATION MAY SUFFER A
SERIOUS JOB RELATED INJURY THAT
FORCES THEM INTO EARLY
RETIREMENT. THOSE PROTECTIONS
WILL SUNSET AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR L. PLACE FIREFIGHTERS AND
OTHER CITY MEMBERS RETIREMENT AT
RISK AB SEVEN TWENTY TO MAKE
INVESTING LAW PERMIT PROTECTING
FIREFIGHTERS AND OTHER STATE
UNIVERSE WHO PUT THEIR LIVES ON
THE LINE TO SERVE US. WITH ME
TODAY IS MEGHAN'S TUBERS
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU MISTER
VICE CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
MEGAN SUPERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS POLICE TO BE-
SPONSORING AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
TWO. AT THE AUTHOR STATED THAT
THAT STATISTIC THAT'S FROM A
RAND CORPORATION STUDY FROM
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TIMES MORE
LIKELY FOR A FIREFIGHTER TO
EXPERIENCE A JOB RELATED INJURY
OR ILLNESS INTO. A PRIVATE
SECTOR WORKER- THIS PROVISION
THAT IS DUE TO SUNSET AT THE END
OF THIS YEAR HAS REALLY BEEN A
LIFESAVER PARTICULARLY FOR- A
FIREFIGHTER A PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICER WHO MAY HAVE HAD THIRTY
YEARS OF SERVICE BUT DID NOT
REACH THAT NORMAL RETIREMENT
AGE- IN CALPERS- THEY DIDN'T
HAVE THIS ABILITY BUT PRIOR TO
PEPPER AT TO. RECEIVE AN
ACTUARIALLY REDUCED AMOUNT
RETIREMENT IF THEY HAD NOT REACH
THE AGE FIFTY- SO THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT AND WILLBRING PARITY
AND CONTINUE PARITY FOR.
FIREFIGHTERS AND PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS
AND COUNTIES THIRTY SEVEN ACTS
SYSTEMS THAT HAVE HAD SIMILAR
PROVISIONS ON THE BOOKS. FOR
MANY YEARS- SO FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
DELETING THE SUNSET WE THINK THE
PREVIOUS EXTENSION HAS SHOWED
THAT IT IS WORKING AND IT IS
NOT- IMPACTING THE STATE IN ANY
NEGATIVE WAY AND WE THINK IT'S-
BENEFICIAL FOR. OUR SAFETY
MEMBERS AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
. ARE THEIR PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. ALL RIGHT
LET'S GO TO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. SEEING NONE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME AND WE GOT A LINE OF
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CARE MEMBERS RANDY PAIRING ON
BEHALF OF PORAC IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
YES. ONE ZERO. AND THEN FURTHER
AT THIS TIME. VERY WELL DO WE
HAVE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. SEEING
NONE DO WE HAVE ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND ROOM. NONE I'M OF
THE BILL. WE HAVE A MOTION WE
HAVE A SECOND ARE THERE ANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE. PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME SO. AND CURRENTLY NONE-
WELL. COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. WE HAVE A MOTION WE
HAVE A SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
WRAP IT UP I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. BY I'M BILL AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY TWO SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTION IS
DEPRESSING BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
COOPER HI COOPER AYE VOEPEL HI
VOEPEL I CALDERON. CALDERON I
COOLEY HI COOLEY FOR DONALD.
O'DONNELL I LACKEY LACKEY I
THANK BILL WITHOUT SUCCESS- THAT
BRINGS US TO ITEM SEVEN A. B.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOPER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR COLLEAGUES I BELIEVE THAT
THE CHANNELS A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THIS THE US MILITARY RESERVES
AND THE CALIFORNIA NATIONAL
GUARD MEMBERS WHO WORK FOR THE
STATE CAN BE ACTIVATED FOR
MILITARY SERVICE. IN TIMES OF
CRISIS THIS IS THE CASE DURING
COVERT WE SERVICE MEMBERS
RUPTURING UNDER PRESIDENTIAL
DECLARATION OF EMERGENCY ONCE
ACTIVATED THE SERVICE MEMBERS
CAN ONLY BE COMPENSATED FOR THE
AMOUNT AUTHORIZED BY THE
NATIONAL GUARD OR RESERVES AND
NOT BY THEIR EMPLOYER. BY LAW
THE SERVICE MEMBERS ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE MADE WHOLE OTHER
COMPENSATION EQUAL TO THEIR
STATE CIVILIAN EMPLOYMENT. THIS
IS NOT HOW IT TRANSPIRED DURING
THE PANDEMIC OF COVERT. DUE TO A
LACK OF CLARITY IN EXISTING LAW
MANY OF OUR SERVICE MEMBERS PAY
WAS DELAYED IN SOME CASES UP TO
A YEAR. IT IS UNTHINKABLE THAT
OUR SERVICE MEMBERS ARE CALLED
IN THE SERVICE. PLACE HARM'S WAY
THE SAME TIME PLACE INTO A
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP. SB SEVEN
SIXTY EIGHT CLARIFIES THE INTENT
OF THE LAW FOR OUR SERVICE
MEMBERS DO NOT HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT MEETING THEIR PERSONAL
FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS. WHEN
CALLED UP TO ACTIVE DUTY. WITH
ME IS MATTHEW EASLEY CHIEF
LOBBYIST FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION THE SPONSORS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MATT EASILY REPRESENT A
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION. WE CAN
SUPPORT AS THE SPONSOR OF AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT. SINCE
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY THE
UNITED STATES IN OPERATING UNDER
PRESIDENTIAL DECLARATION OF
EMERGENCY AS A RESULT OF THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND SINCE
THAT TIME STATE EMPLOYEES WHO
ARE SERVING IN THE NATIONAL
GUARD AND RESERVES HAVE BEEN
ACTIVATED ACROSS THE STATE IN
RESPONSE THAT DECLARATION.
SEVERAL OF THE STATE EMPLOYEES
ARE CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE C. P. O. A.
DESPITE THE CLEAR REASON FOR
THEIR ACTIVATION THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES
HAD CONTINUED TO DENY REQUESTS
FOR DIFFERENTIAL PAY. UNTIL
FINALLY REVERSING THAT DECISION
ON FEBRUARY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. NEED HELP WITH
INDIVIDUALS HAVE SERVED ON THE
FRONT LINES AND COOK NINETEEN
RESPONSE AND THEY WON THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO WAIT ALMOST A
YEAR TO RECEIVE COMPENSATION
PROMISED BY LAW. THE REASON FOR
THE DELAY WITH TH
MISINTERPRETATION OF THE
REFERENCE THE TITLE TEN OF THE
U. S. CODE. THEY REFUSE TO
APPROVE APPROVE THE
DIFFERENTIAL. BECAUSE THAT
AUTHORIZED IN STATUTE WAS NOT
SPECIFICALLY. NOTATE ON THE
SOLDIERS ORDER. HE THOUGH THEY-
A CLEAR STATE OF COOK NINETEEN.
AS THE REASON FOR THAT
ACTIVATION. SEVENTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TO
TAKE PART IN THE FINANCE
FINANCIAL SECURITY OF THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
AND OTHER STATE EMPLOYEES. BY
ENSURING FUTURE DETERMINATION
ARE NOT SIMILARLY IMPACTED BY
THE SAME MISINTERPRETATION I'D
LIKE TO THINK IT'S A MEMBER CAN
PER PROP DURING THE BILL IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERING IT.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
ROOM. ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. DO WE HAVE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND ROOM. SEEING NONE DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IF
YOU SUPPORT. CURRENTLY NONE. DO
WE HAVE ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. THE NONE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE. NONE WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ACTUALLY IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE. YOU WILL FIND THEIR OWN.
I'M NOT A FIFTEEN OKAY ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. AND BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR COMMENTS CONCERNS. I HAVE
ONE COMMENT- HAVING DONE COMBAT
TOURS WHEN YOU'RE ON THE POINTY
END OF THE STICK THE LAST THING
YOU WANT TO WORRY ABOUT IS YOUR
PAYCHECK THIS IS A VERY GOOD
BILL. ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOTHES I WILL
USE. WE HAVE A MOTION TO HAVE A
SECOND. HELLO YES. THANK YOU I
WILL USE THAT AS MY CLOTHES
MISTER CHAIR. SO WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND ON ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON MILITARY AND
VETERAN AFFAIRS COOPER HI COOPER
I VOEPEL HI VOEPEL I GOT I
DON'T. BUY THEIR OWN AYE COOLEY
AYE COOLEY AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL RIGHT LACKEY HI LACKEY
I THAT BILLS OUT. SIX ZERO. WITH
BILL PASSES. TRUMP. OKAY. IT'S
CONFUSING. OKAY NOW TO GET THE
ITEMS ON CALL. THE ITEM NUMBER
ONE EIGHTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOUR
ITEM NUMBER TWO SJR FIVE. THE
CURRENT VOTERS FOR TWO ZERO
O'DONNELL. WELL DONE I MACKEY
MACKEY I **** ARE OUT SIX ZERO.
NOTED RIGHT NUMBER THREE EIGHTY
SIX YOU KNOW FOR THE CURRENT
POTUS FORTY ZERO LACKEY NOPE
MACHENAUD THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE
TO ONE. FIFTY FOUR TO ONE.
NOTICE BY VOTE TO SAY PLEASE.
NOTED LACKEY ABSTAINED. THAT
BILL IS FOUR TWO ZERO. OKAY THAT
BRINGS US TO THE END OF OUR
HEARING. THERE'S NOTHING NO
COMMENTS THE THROUGH THE GERMAN
THANK YOU.